anything else ready to have an idea this
butcher shop offers A Taste of Ukraine
yeah Fresco glass just made now
um 4 800 miles from Keith
this is Ukrainian Village in Ohio home
to the state's largest
ukrainian-american community Luba
molikovski's sister lives in Ukraine
with a newborn
their neighborhood recently hit by a
Russian rocket I'm feeling so bad and
that's so dangerous but what we can do I
don't know one thing she will do is vote
in the upcoming midterm elections hello
Ohio
's Republican senate seat is up for
grabs it's one of a handful of states
that could determine the balance of
power in Washington
opinion polls suggest that the race for
Ohio's all-important senate seat is too
close to call and among the deeply
divisive issues dominating this campaign
is America's ongoing financial support
for Ukraine let's talk about the stakes
of this election Ohio's Republican
candidate has said the U.S should stop
spending tax dollars supporting Ukraine
I gotta be honest with you I don't
really care what happens to Ukraine one
way or another I wanted to ask about
your position on America's continued
support for Ukraine we asked JD Vance to
clarify his stance look I don't think
that we can continue funding the
Ukrainian War indefinitely I would like
us to de-escalate and spend American
dollars on American priorities that
position is backed by a growing number
of Republican lawmakers I think if the
Republicans take control of congresses
it looks like they will I see very
little likelihood of funding continuing
at least at the level that it has the
Democrats meanwhile are pushing for
another Aid package for Ukraine this is
700 some pages this retired journalist
is documenting America's Ukrainian
population 45 000 ukrainians live in
Ohio alone
many including himself are long-time
Republicans now preparing to vote
Democrat they never voted for Democrats
but the the they see that they must in
this case because Ukraine's very
survival is at stake we've had
tremendous support a group representing
Ohio's ukrainians believes members of
the state's large Eastern European
diaspora will also be voting Democrat
the Baltic Republic's estonians latvians
the lithuanians with the polls the
Jewish Community there's a force
multiplier so we have many many allies
in the community I mean let's face it
Ukraine is fighting on because the
Western world's providing the aid in
economic support and the future of U.S
support for Ukraine could hinge on this
election result Jeff sempel Global News
Parma Ohio